Realiza una tabla y resuelve.
Y dice el problema.
Si tienes 50 onzas de una solución salina al 25%, es decir, una mezcla de agua con sal, entonces,
¿Cuántas onzas de solución salina al 10% debes agregar para terminar con una nueva solución salina la 15%?
Y bueno, para resolver este problema, que
te parece si hacemos en principio la tabla.
Así que aquí voy a poner la cantidad total
que tenemos de la solución,
la cantidad total de solución que tenemos, aquí voy a poner el porcentaje que tenemos de salinidad
es decir, el porcentaje de sal que tenemos y aquí voy a poner la cantidad total de sal que tenemos...
la cantidad total de sal que tenemos...
Recuerda que estamos hablando de soluciones
salinas, una parte es agua y otra parte es sal.
Y vamos a ver nuestra cantidad inicial,
nuestra cantidad inicial... déjame escribirlo aquí...
nuestra cantidad inicial, fue de 50 onzas,
entonces aquí le voy a poner que son 50 onzas.
Y estas 50 onzas eran una mezcla salina al
25%, por lo tanto, el porcentaje de sal que
tienen es un 25% y después, aquí voy a poner
la cantidad total de sal que tienen estas
50 onzas, que esencialmente es un 25% de estas
50 onzas y un 25% es lo mismo que tomarme 1/4,
entonces, 1/4 de 50 es 12.5, de estas 50 onzas, 12.5 onzas son de sal si tenemos una solución salina al 25%.
Ahora bien, todo esto es lo que tiene que
ver con la solución inicial,
pero a esta solución inicial le vamos a agregar una cierta solución salina al 10%,
la cual voy a llamar solución agregada.
Y si te das cuenta, en esta ocasión, no nos
dice exactamente cuanto estamos agregando,
de hecho, esto es justo la pregunta.
Y bueno, como no sabemos cuanto vamos a agregar,
vamos a decir que es "x", pero lo que sí
sé es que esta nueva solución que vamos
a agregar, debe de estar al 10% de salinidad,
es decir, es una solución salina al 10%.
Y bueno, utilizando lo mismo que hicimos aquí
arriba, si nosotros lo que queremos saber
es la cantidad total de sal que tiene esta
solución agregada, habrá que multiplicar
el 10% por "x", es decir .1 por "x" porque
por ejemplo, si aquí fuera 50 entonces tendríamos
que multiplicar 10% por 50 onzas y si fuera
25 onzas sería 10% por 25 onzas,
pero en este caso como tenemos "x" onzas, entonces
la cantidad de sal es 10% de estas "x" onzas.
Y bueno, si nosotros combinamos estas dos
soluciones, tanto la solución inicial como
la solución agregada, vamos a obtener una
solución resultante, le voy a poner así.
Y bueno, la cantidad total de solución resultante
que va a haber pues es la cantidad total de
solución inicial, más la cantidad total
de solución agregada, es decir 50 más "x"
porque no sabemos cuanto vamos a agregar.
Y lo que queremos, es que esta solución resultante
esté a un 15% de salinidad, sea una solución
salina al 15%, por lo tanto 15 por ciento
aquí y aquí está lo más importante de este problema,
yo lo que quiero saber es cual
es la cantidad total de sal, que va a tener
esta solución resultante.
Y si te das cuenta, la podemos calcular de
dos maneras, la primera manera es decir, bueno,
tenemos el 15% de salinidad y a esto le voy
a multiplicar por la cantidad total de solución
que hay, es decir 50 más "x", esto si lo
queremos obtener de la misma manera
que lo obtuvimos en las dos filas anteriores.
Ahora, también hay otra manera de hacerlo,
podríamos sumar la cantidad de sal que hay
en las dos soluciones anteriores, es decir,
en la solución inicial y en la solución agregada, es decir, que esto es exactamente
igual a sumar la cantidad de sal que hay en la solución inicial más la cantidad de sal
que hay en la solución agregada, es decir,
12.5 más "0.1x", más "0.1x".
Y bueno, esto es porque es justo lo que queremos, que la cantidad de sal que nosotros estamos agregando,
más la inicial, nos den, la cantidad
de sal de la solución resultante.
¿Y adivina qué?
Aquí ya obtuvimos una ecuación con una incógnita,
por lo tanto de aquí ya podemos despejar
a "x", es una ecuación de primer grado
y recuerda que "x" es justo tras lo que vamos.
Y bueno, 0.15 por 50, es lo mismo que 7.5
y después 0.15 por "x" me da "0.15x", 0.15
por 50 es 7.5 mientras que del otro lado me
queda 12.5 más 0.1 por "x".
Y ahora, si lo que hago primero es restar 7.5 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
¿qué voy a obtener?
déjame cambiar de color y aquí voy a restar
7.5 y aquí también voy a restar 7.5,
de este lado, del lado izquierdo, estos dos se van y me queda que "0.15x" es igual a 12.5 menos 7.5,
lo cual es 5, simple y sencillamente
5, más "0.1x" y ahora lo que voy a hacer
es restar "0.1x" de ambos lados de la ecuación y -0....
Lo voy a poner "-0.10x" y del otro lado "-0.10x",
recuerda que estos dos número son exactamente
lo mismo, de tal manera que del lado derecho
se van a cancelar y del lado izquierdo
me queda "0.05x" es igual a 5.
Y ahora, si divido todo entre 0.05
con esto voy a obtener el valor de "x", todo entre
0.05, estos dos se cancelan
y me queda que "x" es igual a 5 entre 0.05, que es lo mismo que 5 entre 1/20,
que es lo mismo que 20 por 5 lo cual es 100,
"x" es igual a 100, ¡perfecto!
Y realmente está perfecto porque "x" era lo que queríamos, es decir,
vamos a tener que agregar 100 onzas
de solución salina al 10%
para que obtengamos una solución de 150 onzas,
con una salinidad del 15%.
Y ahora sí, si multiplico 100 onzas por 10% me va a quedar 10 y 12.5 más 10 onzas esto
me va a dar 22.5 y date cuenta que 22.5 es
el 15% de 150, de 150 onzas...
¡Y perfecto! Lo hemos logrado.